It's clearly a pretty obvious thing
to stick a bit of filling
between two slices of something
along the lines of bread
and eat it with your hands,
but the British sandwich industry
is worth £8 billion a year.
Across Western Europe and America
sandwiches are booming.
Some made in-home
but most bought on the run.
It's been done
for thousands of years,
whether it's with flatbread or
yeasted loaves, cheese or meat,
especially by those eating
away from a table.
For instance, working on the fields
or as a casual snack.
It wasn't named though
or even recognised
as a thing which needed a name
until the 18th Century.
The story goes that John Montagu,
the 4th Earl of Sandwich,
a town on the
south coast of England,
was at the gambling table one night,
decided not to stop for supper,
and ordered a simple snack of beef
between two slices of bread.
The real story
is a bit less clear cut.
Montagu wasn't a big spender,
he was broke most of the time,
and his idea
didn’t come out of nowhere.
He'd almost certainly seen
pitta breads used with a filling
on his travels
in the Eastern Mediterranean.
Whatever the truth, the concept
was certainly named after him,
and the word
was in fashionable use by the 1770s.
Early sandwiches
stayed close to the original idea,
they were designed for quick eating
initially by men
doing business at coffee houses
or playing cards,
and then for more mixed tea parties,
ball buffets and light suppers.
Early 19th Century sandwiches
were intended to be elegant,
often served on doilies
with the crusts cut off.
But the name was also used
for the age-old worker's meal -
thick bread, butter
and a universal filling of ham.
And by the middle
of the Victorian period
sandwich sellers clustered
around every factory gate.
One writer called them
mouth-distorters,
and pleaded for sandwich makers
to make them delicate and delicious.
His suggested fillings included:
Bone marrow and nasturtium,
potted woodcock,
sliced sweetbreads, sea kale
and oranges soaked in brandy.
A more humble alternative was
provided
by best-selling author
Isabella Beeton.
She suggested a toast sandwich -
literally a slice of cold toast
between two slices of bread,
well-seasoned with salt and pepper.
It was, apparently, particularly
well-suited for invalids.
In the 20th Century
the British sandwich of
two slices of bread and a filling
was joined by other alternatives
from overseas.
The Scandinavian open sandwich
was praised by British food writer
Marguerite Patten in the 1960s.
While filled pittas,
croissants and wraps
have also crept in to join
the basic bread and butter version.
Toasted sandwiches
came out of the States in the 1920s
when the Toastie-Maker was patented.
The US had become sandwich-central,
even briefly having a national
Sandwich Day on November the 3rd -
the original
Earl of Sandwich's birthday.
But it wasn't until 1980
that the pre-packed sandwich
made its first appearance
in Marks and Spencer
and initially only in five stores.
They were an instant hit
and now the working lunch
is almost synonymous
with the prawn cocktail sandwich -
still M&S's biggest seller.
The science behind constructing
a non-soggy sandwich
which can last all day
is very big business indeed.
Of course,
the predictable fillings still vie
with slightly more
avant-garde attempts.
Lasange-wich anyone?
And many sandwich aficionados
swear blind
that the biggest improvement
to any bought sandwich
is a layer of ready-salted crisps.